dans ces modestes bureau au coeur du
vieux montréal
l'avenir de l'agriculture d'hiver est
peut-être en train de s'écrire
l'entreprise sol une technologie conçoit
et fabrique des luminaires à led qui
reproduisent la lumière naturelle note
finale où il est intelligent et capable
de changer et donc de doses et
l'éclairage et le dosage de chacune des
couleurs pour aider la croissance de la
plante louis ibres nous parle de ce
projet pilote en ontario où grâce à ces
luminaires des milliers de poivrons ont
poussé aussi bien que sous le soleil du
mexique
notre système va analyser la lumière qui
entre dans la serre pour la comparer
avec la lumière que le producteur
souhaite avoir depuis calculé la
différence à travers nos algorithmes
puis notre plateforme peau que l'on
vienne compenser et recréer la lumière
idéal pour la culture du poivron
l'intelligence artificielle vise
justement à permettre aux ordinateurs de
penser et d'agir comme des êtres humains
seul hume fait partie des entreprises de
la région en train d'y faire leur marque
elle s'attend à vendre 15000 luminaires
cette année ce lieu mais pas rendu
maintenant à plus de 40 employés
et puis on est inconstante embauches
très concentré présentement au canada au
niveau des opportunités d'affaires
mais on commence à voir des demandes à
l'international depuis cinq ans un
départ le travail du chercheur yoshua
bengio qui dirige l'institut québécois
d'intelligence artificielle le grand
montréal est devenue un pôle dans ce
domaine avec 86 1300 emplois onze mille
étudiants et 300 chercheurs
au québec ce sont 2 milliards 300
millions de dollars qui ont été investis
depuis 2016
on ne pourra pas créer au succès d'un
coeur on ne verra pas la halle est déjà
satisfait se déployer dans nos
entreprises et de nos institutions et
créer des entreprises qui monétise pour
nous le fruit de l'aisne la propriété
intellectuelle louis têtu fait sa part
il dirige coveo une entreprise de
logiciels qui
analyse les données pour que chaque
interaction numérique soit personnalisé
en fonction de l'utilisateur
coveo fait travailler 600 personnes à
montréal et québec et vos plus d'un
milliard de dollars il sera un des
panélistes lors du chemin sur
l'intelligence artificielle qui se
tiendra ici au palais des congrès jeudi
et vendredi un événement surtout virtuel
pandémie oblige qui abordera les défis à
relever pour concrétiser la vence de
montréal dans le secteur
il faut aller plus loin sur la
commercialisation qui ré de la valeur
crée des modèles d'affaires tenable
quand on pense au japon à l'allemagne à
tout ce qui va se passer en californie
où ce qui se passe déjà on voit très
bien que nos moyens sont pas illimités
il va falloir trouver les créneaux
porteurs
comment accompagner ces entreprises pour
que au moment où elles sont prêtes de
récolter le fruit de leur travail mais
qu'à ce moment là ils deviennent pas la
proie de d'entreprises étrangères un des
gros joueurs montréalais la firme
element et haye vient d'être acheté par
une compagnie américaine qui ensuite
créer 200 emplois de plus à montréal
facebook google et microsoft ont aussi
choisi la ville conserver nos
entreprises et nos chercheurs est
difficile selon louis têtu redire la
vérité est là une entreprise comme coveo
sbaâ tous les jours à montréal contre
des entreprises qui ont été attirés par
nos gouvernements dernières années la
plus grande richesse conclut-il c'est
cette main d'oeuvre le talent
montréal comme boston san francisco
londres ou shanghai se bat pour le
garder ou l'attirer c'est une chance
c'est aussi un immense défi ici
jean-sébastien cloutier radio canada bon
rien